[Music]
my name is Antoine Picon and the G we're
traveled sted professor of the history
of architecture and technology at
Harvard Graduate School of Design where
I teach classes in the history of
architecture urbanism and technology
few buildings have marked as important a
moment in the history of architecture as
the Crystal Palace not only will the
building emblematic of a new way to
build using iron at a scale
unprecedented it was also a major
turning point in terms of its use since
it hosted the first world fair and
introduced a whole new spatial
experience the revolutionary nature of
the building was immediately felt by the
contemporaries not only was a building
immense but it introduced the public to
the new realm of merchandise to this
capitalist world full of Wonders as some
critic of the time wrote the building
what seemed as large as the entire
planet this class is about the changes
brought by the first Industrial
Revolution to architecture but both to
the production of buildings and to their
use as we will see the Crystal Palace is
indeed emblematic of major changes in
construction with the adoption of ayran
as well as in the perception of
architecture to understand the scope of
the changes brought by the Crystal
Palace it's necessary to say a few words
on the progress of ayran construction of
course hiren had been known for
thousands of years but it's used at a
massive scale in construction really
started at the end of the 18th century
in 1779 was for instance constructed the
first bridge entirely in cast iron in
Coalbrookdale in England later
Iren would develop both in very
utilitarian construction like bridges
but also in more pleasurable venues such
as greenhouses as we will see
greenhouses have an intimate link with a
conception of the Crystal Palace here we
have the interior of Q garden the green
house by Richard Turner today we find
the use of iron totally normal in
construction we tend to forget by the
same token
that this was not the case prior to the
18th century iron was used mainly for
machines for gongs for cannons but
certainly not in the very large
quantities required by iron construction
the store the modern story of iron in
buildings and infrastructure really
begins during the second half of the
18th century the Crystal Palace was
built to host the first Great Exhibition
that opened in 1851 the Great Exhibition
was unique because it was the first
worldwide show of that size but it was
actually rooted in a longer tradition
that really started in the the 18th
century with a greater and greater
interest taken in technology by all
European elites the Encyclopedia of the
Honda Noble was typical of this interest
for technology in general with it's very
menu description of fabrication like
here for example pin making in an 18th
century factory this interest led the
European elites to try to organize
exhibition showcasing the industrial
production of their respective countries
the ambition to showcase the products of
national industry was especially
pronounced in France in 1798 her first
exhibition was organized in Paris and
later on exhibition of that type were
regularly organized in the French
capital the last one of these exhibition
the one preceding immediately the Great
Exhibition of 1851 was a pretty massive
endeavor hosted in a large temporary
construction near the other lead right
in the middle of Paris at the time the
term industry actually did not cover on
the manufacturing but also all the human
activities related to technology also
noticeable was the presence of
agricultural product in 18-49 for
example cattle was displayed along with
machines so this related really to the
still the 18th century sense of industry
as everything
linked to the productive activities of
man and not only manufacturer as we know
it today
as we will see this extended meaning
will characterize still the the great
1851 exhibition
you